jeer marks the 60th anniversary of the
integration of baseball next on book TV
Jonathan Icke talks about Jackie
Robinson's first season with the
Brooklyn Dodgers in his new book opening
day this is about an hour I had the
pleasure of introducing him two years
ago when he was discussing luckiest man
the life and death of Lou Gehrig and now
to be introducing him as he discusses
his book opening day the story of Jackie
Robinson's first season feels sort of
like a book in experience and I was
thinking about the similarities in the
two men that he's chronicled their
baseball and Beyond in some respects
other aspects of their lives both men
shared these qualities courage
commitment and that that commitment was
not just to playing excellence but to
citizenship and contribution to the
larger society and then the other
quality that both had it indeed was
character they both died young but are
remembered as sports icons and in both
cases as spectacular as their baseball
statistics were there was a lot more to
each man and of course they each
represented fabled New York teams and I
guess mortal enemies and such as the
transition in life that I started out
the fan of one and
later made the crossing to the other but
have an appreciation for the outstanding
players on both teams from excerpts that
I have read from from our authors book
on Jackie Robinson's first season it's
not just the usual account of first he
did this then he did that so forth on
the field you get a feel for the larger
context in which he operated and it's
one of the things for old-timers like me
sold that my son once asked me if there
was an alphabet when I was a kid that I
remember so called baseball history in
which it was just a hagiography these
were wonderful people on the field there
was no discussion of off the field of
course because there might have been a
contradiction there but now to see how
the discipline has matured over the last
30 or so years and that has been to me
evident that not so many years ago there
was a discussion or a journal article on
Jackie Robinson's first season in which
Jackie Robinson all the accounts came
from white newspapers and one of the
things that our author does so well is
to talk about life beyond what the
privileged society
was like if you think about it many of
you might not think about this when
Jackie integrated the baseball field he
went back to a small hotel and when the
team traveled there were places that he
could not stay and it was still almost
completely segregated Society of course
Jackie's breaking the color line made
for a considerable change and even those
people who did not like Jackie Robinson
who felt threatened by Jackie Robinson
certainly by the end of the season
respected him as a capable performer and
a gentleman
[Music]
Jonathan's book is eminently readable as
attested to by his kids and one of the
excerpts I believe it was his son said
he'd liked the book even better than the
first one because it was shorter I don't
I don't know how one could want the book
to be shorter because it is totally
fascinating and as my son told me from
the first day that he went to the first
grade and as a veteran of preschool and
kindergarten and so forth he said to me
very seriously that first day he said
that they're not messing around anymore
well we have an author who is not
messing around and this is a real
pleasure to introduce Jonathan and Ike
thank you very much for coming and
thanks for that nice introduction before
we begin I have to correct an error this
is the National Archives we don't want
to let any errors slip into the record
the your program says that I tried my
hand at big league baseball before
earning a degree in journalism anybody
who knows me from my younger days knows
that I was what they call a four tool
player and Little League I had but
unfortunately all my tools were broken I
had I had no gloves no stick I couldn't
run couldn't throw so I turned to
writing at a very early age recognized
that I was not going to make it on my
athletic skills there's a famous statue
that many of you have probably seen is
in Brooklyn so it's a 8 foot bronze
statue of Jackie Robinson and by his
side is Pee Wee Reese and Pee Wee Reese
is putting his arm up around Jackie's
shoulder Jackie's a little bit bigger
and the plaque on the statue reads that
the statue commemorates a moment in
Cincinnati May 13 1947 and Jackie
Robinson's rookie season on the team's
first road trip when they went to
Cincinnati Jackie Robinson was being
heckled so brutally by the crowd there
that his teammate peewee Reese who was
from Kentucky and had a considerable
following in the crowd walked across the
diamond and in a gesture of support and
brotherhood put his arm around Jackie
Robinson and silenced that that hostile
crowd it's considered one of the great
moments in baseball history there have
been children's books written about it
there have been movies they've been
poems written to this moment it was this
moment that I thought about two years
ago and my Garrett book came out I
received a letter from a reader saying
maybe you should consider doing a book
about Jackie Robinson and Pee Wee Reese
friendship the friendship between these
two Brooklyn Dodgers and I love the fact
the first I was flattered that I
received you know a letter from a fan
who wanted me to write another book
that's great if anybody in the audience
has any ideas for future books I'm all
ears
but don't shout them out because I think
there are some other writers in the room
tonight this afternoon but when I when I
heard this idea I thought it's not that
it's not bad it's a little saccharine
perhaps but I thought it was worth look
into at least to see how much was there
to that friendship in 1947 how much did
peewee Reese mean to Jackie Robinson and
and how did the friendship take root in
this climate of hostility when when
black and white were so distrustful of
each other and when very few people were
willing to welcome Jackie Robinson into
the league and what I found almost
immediately was that the embrace did not
occur it did not happen in 1947 Jackie
Robinson writing just a few years later
said he remembered a similar incident in
1948 or 49 and Pee Wee Reese himself
said he didn't remember any such
incident in 47 I went back through all
the old newspaper accounts black and
white papers from Cincinnati and New
York looking for any mention of this
incident found no photographs found no
mention at all and in fact found that
Robinson wrote in his column that day he
wrote a column for the Pittsburgh
courier the black paper in his column he
wrote that Cincinnati fans were among
the kindest he's encountered yet and
even some of the white newspapers in New
York noted that Robinson was treated
much better in Cincinnati than he had
been and other stops along the way and I
talked to some eyewitnesses people who
were at the game that day fans said that
they didn't they didn't certainly don't
remember anything like that happening
the stands were Kratt were packed with
black people that day Cincinnati the
West End Crosley Field was in the West
End which was a largely black
neighborhood and black fans in many ways
crowded out the white fans that day and
their impression was that the white fans
had been intimidated as if they felt
like heckling Jackie Robinson they
wouldn't have dared suddenly there's a
problem with my book idea peewee and
Jackie his best friend on the other hand
it occurred to me if peewee Ruiz wasn't
there for Jackie Robinson who was if he
didn't have the support of the Dodgers
captain and that point you're the
unofficial captain of the Dodgers in
1947 then who did he get support from
how did he get through this year in
which his own teammates threatened to
boycott threatened not to play suddenly
I thought maybe that's my story maybe
the entire experience of Jackie Robinson
be could be crystallized into that 1947
in season and you could look at how he
goes from a ballplayer
just trying to break in just trying to
get a chance just trying to prove that
he belongs in an environment in which
his own teammates not to mention the
opposition would desperately like to see
him gone to leading his team to the
pennant that season and presumably
winning their hearts and minds that's
where I began that's where the premise
that's where this germ of an idea for
this book grew I looked at my calendar
that day and realizes the sixtieth
anniversary for Robinson's first game
was coming up fast and if I liked this
idea for a book I'd better get moving
and I did one of the first things I did
was to begin reading histories of the
era now growing up as a baseball fan I
was more a fan than player as I
mentioned I learned a lot about history
as a kid from baseball and I'll bet you
there are a lot of people in the
audience who would say the same you know
I just devoured these old baseball books
these biographies that were written for
our young readers and you would pick up
just little glimmers of history and
reading them and you wouldn't even know
you were getting that history you know
you read about Babe Ruth and you learn
about prohibition because he was you
know along with Al Capone
one of the chief rifles and one of the
people who enjoyed that the 20s perhaps
more than it more than anyone else in
the country reading about Jackie
Robinson of course you learned about Jim
Crow and segregation so I began and I I
think I was at my I was a baseball
historian in my in my own right as a kid
because I would keep my box scores of
every game I went to and stick them in
my desk drawer and could go back years
later and look at who the my favorite
players were and how they did on the
days that I saw them play and I think we
learned to record history at least for
me I learned to record history and to
appreciate it a little bit at first
through baseball and so when trying to
get at 1947 one of the first things I
had to do was understand the climb at
the times that we were in and it was a
time at Arthur Schlessinger wrote a
great history was I think this was he
wrote this in 48 but he was writing
about the same era he wrote the grounds
of our civilization of our certitude of
breaking up under our feet and familiar
ideas and institutions vanish as we
reach for them like shadows
the falling dusk so this is just after
World War two
the country is really on uncertain
footing you know we're still just
beginning to wake up to the atrocities
of the Holocaust we're just beginning to
realize that we've won this war but what
does it mean what does it mean for our
democracy the black newspapers are
calling out for another victory the
double V campaign they call it we've
achieved victory in Europe now we need
to fight for victory in our in our own
country so that the black people coming
back in particularly black soldiers
coming back from the war will have
something some stake in this country
that they they what do they fight for if
they're going to come home and be
treated as second-class citizens at the
same time people are yearning for a
sense of normalcy again everything is is
up in arms the whole country is in chaos
there's food shortages in Europe and in
the United States
Truman's ordering rationing of meat and
people look at baseball and say baseball
at least gives us a sense of what we
used to be as a throwback and that's why
we love the game today although it's
getting harder and harder to see it as
an old-time game with so much money
involved but in 1947 DiMaggio Ted
Williams Bob Feller were coming back
after years missed because they were in
the service and Americans just cling to
baseball in 1946 attendance is breaking
records in every ball park in the
country and people are coming out and
and finding that this is this offers
them some solace and then in 1947 Jackie
Robinson comes along and baseball's just
as chaotic as everything else suddenly
all the old rules don't apply anymore
everything is out the window to
understand that I began calling all the
old-timers as any as I could ball
players who were still around from 47
there were quite a few and I asked my
father in fact - you know my father
lived in Queens and my grandfather had
season tickets to Ebbets Field and I
asked my dad well you remember about
that 1947 season he was nine years old
and he said oh I have a lot of great
memories of that season unfortunately I
don't remember what they are I was one
of those Yogi Berra isms I think but
unfortunately other people had better
memories and the old-timers there were
who played with Jackie that year now
when you talk to him they all tell the
stories about how they were they were so
eager to embrace Jackie Robinson Ralph
Branca told me that on opening day 19 4
the first game of the season April 15th
he made a point of standing next to
Jackie Robinson during the singing of
the national anthem and he said after
the game his brother kind of teased him
he said what are you doing standing next
to that guy what if a sniper takes a
shot at him and misses him by three feet
and gets you instead these ball players
all want to be associated with him now
but the truth is that in April 15 1947
nobody would shake Jackie Robinson's
hand in the clubhouse there was no
meeting called by the manager of the
team to get them behind this effort
Jackie Robinson was entirely alone and
that's what intrigued me about this
season how much could I explore what he
really went through and one of the other
things I did early on was go back and as
John made mention I went back through
all the old newspaper clippings to see
how these games were covered not only in
the black media but in the white media
as well it's interesting especially on
that first day April 15th 1947 this is a
big day obviously we were celebrating it
now 60 years later with incredible
hoopla feels like a national holiday but
on April 15th 1947 the white newspapers
didn't mention Jackie Robinson's arrival
it was buried if mentioned at all in the
bottom of these sports stories in the
bottom of the game story not on the
front page not even on the front page of
the sports section but at the bottom of
a story that reported that the Dodgers
beat the Braves 5 to 3 the times New
York Times story didn't mention it at
all it was only carried in one of the
columns that ran as a sidebar to the
game story the black media of course on
the other hand had this story stripped
across the top of every paper every
black paper in the country this was
their banner headline the Pittsburgh
courier the Chicago Defender the New
York Amsterdam News had pages and pages
of photos devoted to the event one
newspaper reporter filed a story just on
where Jackie Robinson sat during each
inning during the game you know inning
by inning account of where he sat on the
bench and who sat next to him because
that was important the black press
recognized that who was willing to sit
next to Jackie Robinson said something
was it just the rookies was it just the
the you know the fellow outcast or would
any of the team's leaders make a gesture
of support in his direction and sure
enough like as often happens with
rookies he was consigned to the end of
the bench sitting mostly with with the
other rookies okay I think at one point
he sat
to one of the assistant coaches but he
was again forced to face this battle on
his own now I should backtrack a little
bit and tell you that in the spring
training of that season when it was not
clear whether Robinson would make the
team at least six of his teammates came
out and said they were willing to make a
stand they were willing to go public and
refused to play with him that they would
demand a trade or Robinson had to go or
they had to go those players were mostly
southerners Dixie Walker Eddie stanky
Bobby breagan some say Pee Wee Reese was
a member of that rebellion Reese always
said he wasn't I could not find any
conclusive evidence one way or the other
but the rebellion was quickly put down
Leo Durocher who was the manager of the
tie at the time he would later be
suspended that season but he was the
manager and spring training was this
unbelievably scary guy just pure rage a
very violent character took no guff he
called a meeting in the middle of the
night in the hotel room in Cuba showed
up wearing pulled the players out of the
rooms you know in various states of
undress and wearing his bright yellow
bathrobe said to his team you know I
don't care if this guy is black white
yellow green or a zebra if he can play
he's going to be on this team and you
can take your petition and stick it up
here you know what and Durocher even if
you've been wearing footie pajamas with
teddy bears on it would have had no
question of his authority the players
immediately back down Branch Rickey flew
in the next day and told them much the
same that if they weren't willing to
play they'd be traded he asked each one
of them will you play or will you or do
you want to go I talked to Bobby breagan
who was the backup catcher really the
third-string catcher I mean there had a
very marginal hold on his job and yet he
was willing to make this protest willing
to risk his career a big league career
is a big deal bigger at the time perhaps
and it is now they're only 400 people in
the big leagues
the breagan said I'd rather be traded
and I asked him bad a tease he said I
was a white supremacist he said that
doesn't mean I wore a Klan row it means
that I believed whites was supreme that
they were superior to whites in every
you to blacks in every way and that if
Jackie Robinson were allowed to cross
that line
all my values would crumble I could not
go home I could not go back to my family
my community would would distrust me
because this is what we were raised to
believe he said I had black family in my
house all the time but they were
cleaning the dishes they were mowing the
lawn they would come in and entertain
for us thought of having somebody
treated and equal to me or even somebody
who might be treated as superior to me
because he's in the starting lineup and
I'm not I couldn't handle it
but he told Branch Rickey that day that
if he had to he would play he backed
down and this is a huge moment for the
team because these players are
essentially choosing their game choosing
their love for the sport over their
prejudice they're at least willing to
live with this and see what happens
which is all Branch Rickey had ever
hoped for Rickey is the general manager
the president and part owner of the
Dodgers I said I should mention in a
fascinating character he really wanted
to integrate because he believed it was
the right thing to do he also really
wanted to integrate because he believed
there was money to be made he had the
worst team in New York City the team
that drew the smallest crowd and he
sensed there was a possibility here to
be more competitive by bringing in black
players because this was his untapped
talent pool he also knew that he could
pay them very little because they would
have no other options
so he was a very complex man doing the
right thing and also doing the cheap
thing almost every step of his of his
career fortunately his commitment to
bringing in Jackie Robinson was so great
that it helped us you know overlook some
of his parsimonious ways and he decided
on Jackie Robinson we might pause again
and ask why Jackie Robinson he was not
the best black player in the Negro
Leagues not by far there were many more
qualified players I think he chose
Jackie Robinson because he was a little
bit older he was 28 he was a very smart
guide gun to UCLA didn't graduate but he
was a very smart guy and most of all I
think he chose Jackie Robinson because
he was a tough guy the famous story is
that Branch Rickey said to Jackie
Robinson can you turn the other cheek
are you strong enough to turn the other
cheek and Jackie Robinson said yes so we
have this image of Robinson
as this martyr as this pacifist he was
not at all he was a rage-filled man he
was angry all his life and nothing made
him angrier than being treated by being
mistreated by white people
he saw racism in every glance he was
court-martialed in 1944 for refusing to
go to the back of a bus when he was in
the army and he beat the charge and thus
saved his career but this was this was a
guy who Ricky was taking a chance with
because he had to know that if Robinson
was provoked and people were going to
provoke him without a doubt and he
responded in anger if he threw a punch
or even if he just went on a tirade and
threw a fit that it might be the end and
who knows how many years it would take
to set how many years that was said
integration back and what tone it would
send but I think the important thing is
that Ricky wanted to send the tone of
strength he wanted to say that we're not
just asking blacks to assimilate to to
go along and get along and and find
their way and slip quietly into the game
he was saying that we are going to send
a message that black Americans are here
and black Americans are part of baseball
now and you got to deal with them and
this is a man that you have to deal with
Jackie Robinson was not someone to be
trifled with
so on that opening day I mentioned that
the black newspapers covered it in the
white newspapers didn't another
interesting point is that white fans did
not show up at the game black fans did
three fifths of the crowded Ebbets Field
was was african-american and the 6,000
seats were empty which suggests that
white fans were staying away in huge
numbers because they were afraid of what
was going to happen
there was a lot of talk about this in
the media a lot of people felt like
Branch Rickey strategy was going to
backfire that sure he might attract some
more black fans to the ballpark but
white fans would stay away and the black
newspapers were writing that it was
really up to african-american baseball
fans to be on their best behavior and
not do anything to make this job harder
for Jackie Robinson than it already is
every ballpark the Jackie Robinson
visited that year there were these
warnings from the black press saying
remember don't drink don't celebrate too
much don't embarrass Jackie Robinson
anyway it was really a community-wide
effort Robinson and that first game goes
over three he gets on base on an error
and scores a run which turns out to be
the winning run
and I it was funny I talked to gene
hermanski who was the leftfielder that
day and he said you know George
Washington didn't know it when he was
making history and Abraham Lincoln
didn't know he was making history when
he delivered the Gettysburg Address and
I didn't know I was making history
either when I drove in the first black
man ever to cross the plate and step on
home plate and score run in baseball I'm
the one who drove him in I didn't know I
was making history but I was and I said
Jean you better go back and look at the
boxcar you drove in the fifth run that
day Jackie Robinson was the fourth he
said I didn't he said he said IgE
started again he said Abraham Lincoln
didn't know he was making history I
didn't know I was making history don't
don't try to get these guys to change
their stories after 60 years I'm telling
you it's brutal as I began to chronicle
the stories I realized that these ball
players tended to embellish their
memories a little bit I quickly
recognized that there was one source for
the story that I had to have one key
person to this entire story who could
open this up to me in a way I wanted to
set this set Jackie Robinson his in his
historical context I wanted to show what
he meant to America not now with the
gloss of 60 years but but right then and
there how he changed lives in the moment
and I wanted to show what his personal
journey was like what he experienced and
the key to that was was his wife Rachel
Robinson's was 85 years old and lives in
Connecticut and is still sharp as a tack
you probably saw her on TV this weekend
for some of the anniversary event so I
called up her office and asked for an
appointment and I got the qolt the
brush-off and I called and called and
finally I got 10 minutes on the phone
with her she you know answered some few
questions but she's clearly going
through the motions she gives a lot of
interviews and I wasn't getting through
to her I finally asked her secretary to
make an appointment for me I came to New
York and met her I walked into the
office I asked for an hour I walked into
the office with bouquet of flowers and a
box of candies and a copy of my Lou
Gehrig book to give her and she comes in
wearing this immaculate suit and sit
down at the table across from me and
says you have 20 minutes and she just
didn't give me an inch and I consider
myself a pretty good interviewer I'm
I work very hard to get people to warm
up and you can't do it in 20 minutes
so I left that interview very frustrated
feeling like my book was going to have a
hole in its heart that its soul would be
missing without her over the next few
weeks and months I began just sending
her stuff in the mail that I would come
across in my research I found a picture
of her getting her hair done at a beauty
salon in Harlem before the World Series
and I put it in an envelope available to
her everything I found that I thought
was was was interesting like that I I
went to the apartment where they lived
they lived in this tiny apartment
5:26 McDonagh Avenue in Brooklyn in the
bedford-stuyvesant neighborhood they
didn't even have their own apartment
they rented a room was about eight by 10
and they had a five month old baby so
there's three people living in this room
they don't even have their own bathroom
or their own kitchen they're sharing it
with this woman who just happened to
hear that they were looking for a place
they didn't even know the woman and
Rachel said they they didn't like her
very much she had a boyfriend and was
always hogging the the living room so
they couldn't even use the living room
these were horrible conditions for for a
young family it's not what you imagined
you know certainly a rookie today and
the major leagues would be accustomed to
so I went to that apartment took
pictures of the room where they stayed
and stuck them in the mail and sent them
to her on eBay I bought a pin that they
were selling in 1947 outside the
ballpark it said I'm for Jackie Robinson
it was printed by one of the union's you
know the union movement in the Communist
Party were huge forces in fighting for
Jackie Robinson's right to play in 1947
and I sent to that pin like I came I
came back for another interview with her
second time and this time she gave me
about 45 minutes warmed up to me
slightly and then I got her to agree to
what to the third meeting she said this
is your last one when I showed up for
that third meeting and just before I
gone I'd gone to the Newark Public
Library and Rachel had told me
throughout all these interviews that she
couldn't remember the name of the woman
she lived with in 1947 the woman who had
that apartment and I would been at the
New York Public Library that morning and
I found the name in a reverse telephone
directory and while we were sitting down
I we were talking and I pulled it out of
my pulled a copy of the page from the
phone directory out of my file and put
it across the desk of Mable Brown is
that ring a bell
oh yes that's it I for sixty years I
haven't been able to remember that name
Mayo Brown god I hated that woman and we
had our first really good interview I
began getting her to remember what they
did at night what kind of card games
they played on the bed in their room how
Jackie struggled some days to control
his temper at home not with them but
just that he would gnash his teeth at
night how he would some days he would
she would know to leave him alone and
not ask any questions in other days she
would ask him detailed detailed
questions about the baseball game
because baseball was the way that she
got him to open up and to talk about his
feelings and how she began to realize
that he was expressing his anger on the
ball field in a way that was so
productive and it really made him stand
out from the white players - she was so
proud of him because he was using these
Negro League baseball tactics to make
himself so effective in the white major
leagues he was taking these long leads
he was taking these big turns around the
bag he was even if he didn't do anything
he was always a threat to steal a base
and that was so unnerving it so rattled
his opponents and it was his way of
getting back at these people that he
couldn't take a punch at or that he
couldn't call names when they were
calling him names all season long and I
remember at one point I said I said okay
so he'd come home and you'd eat some
dinner and go for a walk you said we
didn't have any friends we didn't go out
at night we take the baby for a walk in
the stroller and I said so when you come
back where do I said where'd you park
the stroller by the way did you bring it
any apartment did you leave in the hall
she said finally she's like snapped out
of this this great state she'd been in
she said Jonathan that's enough for 60
years I've kept people out of this
apartment and I'm not letting you back
in there now but by then it was too late
I was in I had my foot in the door and
as I was leaving the interview that day
we had a really nice long talk and she
came to me at the elevator she came down
the hall as I was waiting for the
elevator and she said there was one more
thing that I wanted to tell you people
don't realize how religious Jackie was
how much how much his faith meant to him
we didn't have a church in Brooklyn that
year but every night he would kneel by
the side of the bed and pray and I was
so touched by this that she first of all
wanted to share something extra with me
after if I'd been pulling teeth for
the better part of the year but that I
had been given this this insight this
view into their apartment and now I felt
like I had the heart of my book I had
the story that that I felt nobody had
told before the baseball stuff was great
fun and I loved researching and I loved
talking to the ball players but this was
the piece of the puzzle that had been
missing I felt and so much of what had
been written about Jackie Robinson now
to get back to baseball for a minute I
should tell you that after a very rough
April in May
Robinson starts to hit really hit the
ball and this is not a great Dodger team
this is a team that has very poor
pitching Ralph rancors their only
reliable starter that year they have no
power hitters whatsoever Jackie Robinson
leave the team along with Pee Wee Reese
with 12 homers at the end of the season
and yet beginning May and June they're
in first place and they stay there and
they're doing it nobody really
understands how because they're doing
all the little things they're stealing
their bunting they're getting on base
they're moving the runner ahead and
these are all the things that Jackie
Robinson does best he is without a doubt
the most important player on the team
that year and even the guys who had
protecta protested his arrival in spring
training Dixie Walker who always
complained that he had this hardware
store back in Alabama that he would
never be able to set foot in again that
customers would never come if they knew
that he shared a clubhouse shared a
locker room shared a shower with Jackie
Robinson even Dixie Walker at some point
that summer I believe in July is
overheard by a reporter giving Robinson
some tips on hitting he tells Robinson
that he's pulling the ball far too much
and that especially with men on first
and second he needs to try to to go to
right-field
so the players are coming around and
this is just a remarkable achievement
this has not happened in any other
institutions in our country it's not
until the next year and I think Jackie
Robinson gets some of the credit it's
not until the next year that Harry
Truman orders the the desegregation of
the military government offices are not
are still segregated in 1947 Jackie
Robinson is comes first and he shows
that it can be done not with a court
order and not with armed guards but by
good old American competition by giving
a guy a chance to prove that he can play
and he plays and he says one day
thereafter one of his games now all
season long the White
Porter's are blowing the story nobody
bothers to ask Robinson what he's going
through how he's feeling but there's one
reporter who shows up at at his
apartment one day and asks him and
Robinson says I know I have a
responsibility to my race but I've got
to try not to think about it because it
would be too much of a strain just say I
know this year is the test he knows
exactly what's at stake he's reading
these black newspapers that describe him
on April 15 one of them called him the
most important American black American
in the history of our country and they
go on and on they say he's more
important than Frederick Douglass for
this reason he's more important than
George Washington Carver for this reason
he's got to read this and still go out
and play every day you know I used to
say that and I still think that Lou
Gehrig's performance in 1938 when he
played a whole season with ALS is
perhaps the most remarkable
single-season accomplishment in baseball
history but Jackie Robinson playing
every day in 1947 knowing the burden
that is on him knowing that half of the
guys out there on the other teams are
opposed to him playing and in many cases
are taunting him sometimes trying to
hurt him it's certainly right up there
and and what he does his ability to
recognize that without the hitting
nothing else matters if he doesn't
continue to play well it's not going to
happen for him all season long he
continues to hit he doesn't skip a day
doesn't take a day off you know when the
season begins it's not clear that he's
even going to be a regular first baseman
the Dodgers are carrying two of their
first baseman on the roster but over
time Branch Rickey who's trying to show
Jackie Robinson to support starts
peeling them off he traded them away he
trades away some of the opponents of
integration as well he trades kirby
higbe e to the Pirates because Higby had
been so outspoken in his belief that
blacks should not be in baseball he
keeps Dixie Walker though because he
needs him frankly and and Branch Rickey
still wants to win so going down the
stretch into the end of the season
the Dodgers go to st. Louis for on their
last road trip of the year with a chance
to clinch the pennant and the Cardinals
have been one of the worst antagonists
of Robinson all year early in the season
at least a handful of players threatened
to boycott their game it's not clear
whether it really amounted to a
full-fledged
threat in which the entire team was
talking about walking but at least a few
of them were threatened to walk back in
August
eNOS slaughter
and Spike Jackie Robinson on a close
play at first base that Robinson
believed was intentional and actually
most of the people in the press corps
even in the white press corps said it
looked like it was intentional and if I
can take a little diversion here just as
a very interesting historical side note
sitting on the first base line that day
and the stands was a young kid named
Douglas Wilder who would go on to become
the governor of Virginia now often as I
mentioned some of these guys invent
these stories and say they were there a
game that they really weren't Douglas
Wilder was absolutely there and I can go
into detail about how I know he was
absolutely there but he heard that some
of the guys and his neighborhood
barbershop we're going to see Jackie
Robinson play and he was only a kid they
were grownups but he talked himself into
the backseat of that car as you can
imagine he was a pretty good talker even
at that age and he wanted to go see the
Cardinal because he was a Cardinal fan
he wanted to see Stan Musial and eNOS
slaughter his favorite players but when
eNOS slaughter spiked Jackie Robinson
something started to eat at Doug Wilder
and he told me that the whole ride home
to Virginia in that car something was
bothering he couldn't figure out what it
was and he realized that he couldn't
root for the Cardinals anymore that he
that Jackie Robinson was playing for his
team now and the Jackie Robinson offered
opportunities for a young kid like him
that might not otherwise be available
and it was one of the many epiphanies
that occurred in ordinary people in 1947
and when you read my book it's one of my
favorite things to do in this book is to
slip in those little epiphanies another
one of them that you'll read about in
the book is Malcolm X who was listening
to Jackie Robinson from prison and on
the radio in 1947 or a white kid named
Gil Jonas who was 17 years old and
interviewed Jackie Robinson for his
school paper that day and didn't think
to ask him a single question about race
only asked him about the Cardinals and
who are the tough pitchers and what he
thought the Dodgers chances were that
year and then went to Stanford the next
year as a freshman and was shocked to
see that Stanford was all white because
his baseball team his favorite team was
was integrated why shouldn't Stanford be
integrated and he started the first
chapter of the n-double a-c-p at
Stanford and got to school segregated
school integrated excuse me and then
spent the rest of his career working as
a fundraiser for the end of
KCT these are the ripples that jackie
robinson is causing in 1947 when now to
take you back to st. Louis and that that
final series against the Cardinals I
want you know to see what what we what
how it felt in 1947 at the end of that
season in this game Robinson has spiked
yet again this is the last game of the
year on the road against the Cardinals
their dreaded rivals and Joe Garagiola a
close play at first drives his spikes
into Jackie Robinson's foot so even now
after he's approved himself he's already
been named the Rookie of the Year for
the league they used to give you a word
then before the end of the seasons
Robinson is still facing these threats
he still feels like Garagiola may have
done it on purpose Garagiola has always
said he didn't but next time up when
Robinson comes up to bat he says
something over his shoulder to Garagiola
he feels like he's been around long
enough now that maybe he can give a
little bit of lip he's established
himself well enough that he can let a
little bit of that anger out and
Garagiola it was also a bit of a hothead
gets up from the Crouch and he and
Jackie Robinson are chest to chest ready
to go at it until they're pulled apart
by the umpire and by the coaches who
rush out of the dugout next time he
comes up to bat Jackie Robinson hits a
home run it gives the Dodgers a two to
one lead going into the ninth inning and
Robinson was playing first base he
played all play first base in 1947 not
second there's a foul ball with two outs
hit over by the Dodger dugout and
Robinson goes over to try to catch it
leans over and the dugout catches the
ball it starts to fall in and and Ralph
Branca his teammate leaps from his seat
and grabs Robinson and pushes him back
onto the field and tackles him on the
grass soft landing what otherwise might
have been very painful and the team all
rushes out of the dugout and they
congratulate Robinson on this great
catch they congratulate Ralph Branca on
the other great catch and Robinson says
after the game that he was so pleased
because a few months earlier he didn't
know that anybody on the team would have
bothered to break his fall so the team
at that point is celebrating that
they've locked up the pennant they get
on the train they go back to Brooklyn
and play dough back to New York they
pull into Penn Station and waiting for
them there are thousands and thousands
of fans
to greet them to congratulate them with
signs saying bring on the Yankees we're
the champs we you know Jackie Robinson
gets off this train and he rushes to a
phone booth to try to call his wife to
say he's back and this mob starts
following him and they trap him in the
phone booth it's probably the first time
in American history that a black man has
been chased by a white mob intent on
hugging him he escapes from the from the
phone booth and with a police escort and
makes his way for the subway again these
ballplayers did not have limousines
waiting for them back then and these
fans are all following him they want to
pay his subway fare for him and they
crowd into the train with him and just
escort him home the train car is packed
with Dodger fans I looked through that
picture to the pictures of that event
The Daily News there were lots of photos
of the celebration looking for images of
my father or my grandfather thinking
that it wouldn't it be nice if they'd
been there that day and I think just
like these guys today who all want to be
remembered as part of the Jackie
Robinson story who all want to be
connected with this great man even
though they wouldn't shake his hand at
the start of the season it's an
association we all want to have today
and I thought it was wonderful to see so
many ballplayers on Sunday wearing the
number 42
some people said to me do you think it
was overkill do you think it was
commercialism I said no I think this is
a guy that nobody wanted to touch he had
to stay in separate hotels from his team
he had to eat on his own he couldn't
travel in certain cities without being
you know afraid for violence there were
death threats and now 60 years later
everyone wants to wear his number I
think it's great and I think it's
because he stands for something so much
bigger than baseball democracy was put
to the test after the war Jackie
Robinson was the leading symbol of the
new way of doing things he proved that
if you gave some people a chance if you
give Outsiders new ideas if you give
these things a chance
it makes your team better it made the
Dodgers better it made America better
and I'd like to think that by writing
this book I've helped to set the story
straight I've helped to return Robinson
to his full humanity I'd rather see him
as a real three-dimensional
then an eight-foot statue in bronze and
I've found my way of connecting to the
story as well and I'm proud to be able
to tell the story and I'm happy to be
able to share it with you today so I
thank you for coming and we have some
time for questions and I would just ask
that you come down he's on the
microphone so that the cameras will be
able to pick up your your questions yes
awesome into Dubai
so I was just curious what was there did
you do in your research when your
research did you did you detect that
kind of schizophrenic perception on the
part of black America to accept baseball
I mean to accept Jackie Robinson's
introduction into white baseball but yet
realizing that it would mean the demise
of the black baseball league and the
other question I have is that when I was
little I remember reading about Shirley
Povich and he was supposed to be one of
the biggest advocates white advocates
for the integration of baseball and you
mentioned earlier that there was very
little discussion of when he doing his
inaugural day in the baseball I'm just
kidding I'm just curious what was what
does your research shown regarding
Shirley Povich support of Jackie Robson
during those days those are good
questions honestly your second one first
Shirley Povich was one of the very few
white writers in the country who really
got it and paid attention to Robinson's
debut on April 15th 1947 he also did a
terrific job of documenting the way some
of the black players who came after
Robinson in 47 were treated which was
not very well the same
was Browns this is a little-known
historical fact I think unfortunately
the st. Louis Browns later in 1947 hired
two black players and dismissed them
after a month after giving them very
little chance opportunity to play and
Shirley Povich was all over that story
as well to your first question
schizophrenic is a good way to describe
the reaction of black America I think in
47 it was absolute jubilation at this
opportunity that Robinson had been given
and it was so exciting people to go see
him play there were special train lines
established throughout much of the
country to take people to the ball parks
you know the first time you played in
st. Louis train lines would bring people
from all around the area the first time
you played in Chicago black crowds were
coming out in huge numbers and there was
definitely a sense that this was a new
dawn of a new day and that integration
was something that that we that the
country badly needed at the same time
they did realize as you know as you
noted that it would probably mean the
demise of the Negro Leagues and Negro
leaguers the ballplayers were divided
they felt like if you're good enough
you're going to get to go but they're
gonna be a whole lot of us left behind
and even in 1947 attendance was way down
at Negro league ballparks so they could
see it's not as if this was just the
first whiff of the of a foul odor this
they knew right away that there would
not be that they would not last long
Jackie Robinson had it had a huge impact
right away their question on the side
one of the reactions was by Langston
Hughes in a famous passage about when
beginning when I saw Jackie Robinson hit
that home run my question is was Jackie
Robinson aware of Hughes reaction and
did he personally know Langston Hughes
that's a good question I don't know that
there was any contact between Robinson
and Hughes there was also a great Count
Basie song and that was the first lyrics
were written in 1947 did you see Jackie
Robinson hit that ball Hughes was
writing columns all season long in the
Chicago Defender and about Jackie
Robinson so he was writing about him
often I'm sure he must have seen him
play but there's no I'd no evidence that
there was contact Jackie Robinson's main
the press was Wendell Smith of the
Pittsburgh courier Wendell Smith was his
roommate on the road the Dodgers
actually hired him to travel with
Robinson because none of about white
ballplayers would room with him so and
in cities where they couldn't find
hotels with where the white and black
players couldn't stay together Wendell
Smith and Jackie Robinson would go off
on their own and find either houses to
stay with you know prominent black
citizens homes or in black owned hotels
and it was up to Wendell Smith often to
arrange for black taxi companies to come
pick them up and find like restaurants
where they could eat so Wendell Smith
was was a very important player in this
in the story of Jackie Robinson's
success in 1947 yes yes I was curious
about Jackie Robinson's salary in 1947
compared to other rookies with his same
skill sets and also not only 47 but in
subsequent years of his career in 1947
Jackie Robinson made the league minimum
$5,000 and he probably brought in at
least one hundred two hundred thousand
dollars in extra revenues for the
Dodgers that year just because they were
attracting so many fans everywhere they
went and he certainly made Branch Rickey
a wealthy man and the following season
Branch Rickey rewarded him with a very
small raise and Jackie Robinson accepted
the first offer that Rickey gave him in
1948 so he was making in 48 far less
than other players on the Dodgers who
were not nearly as talented but perhaps
were older and as a result had built up
Robin Ricky was a even no matter how
enlightened he was another way as he was
not very enlightened when it came to to
writing checks and he really believed
that Robinson would not was not entitled
to big raise until he proved himself a
few more years in the league and
Robinson always I think felt great
admiration for Rickey but his wife in
particular was was bitter about that
that issue yes
you said that you started out the book
with the story about peewee Reese and
Jackie Robinson and did the research and
found that it the the actual events did
not happen the way sort of the myth was
created and I remember the children's
book that you had mentioned there was a
short children's book about that did you
were able to sort of to find out how
this myths began yeah I think the myth
began because peewee Reese and Jackie
Robinson did become very good friends in
later years and forty-eight Jackie
Robinson switches from first base to
second so their DoublePlay partners and
they're often together on the field
during pitching changes during timeouts
and I think people got used to seeing
them together and I'll you know how it
is on a pitching change the guys will
get together in the middle infield and
tell jokes and rib each other and that
was a startling sight and I think in 48
and 49 Robinson was still getting some
some heckling probably throughout his
career he was still getting heckling
from racists and I do think at some
point Rob Rickey excuse me Pee Wee made
a point of going over and putting an arm
around Robinson's shoulder to silence
those hecklers because Robinson and
Rickey both said they remembered an
incident Robinson said it was in 48 in
Boston I think and Reese said it was in
Philadelphia in 49 neither of them put
it in Cincinnati in 47 and I just think
that writers over the years felt like
the story would be a little bit more
powerful a little bit more evocative if
you made it in that first season 1947
not only is that unfortunate because
accuracy is to be cherished but it's
also unfortunate because it sends the
message that Robinson couldn't have done
it without the help of this white man
and I think that diminishes his
accomplishment because he was very much
alone that year and nobody on the team
ever invited him out to dinner
in 1947 nobody on the team asked his
wife to sit with the other wives or to
visit with them when the guys were on
the road these guys had to prove
themselves and had to establish
themselves before anybody was really
willing to give him a chance and that's
not as easy to capture in a statue but
that's the truth of the matter yes
another question on this side yes thank
you
first of all I enjoyed your speech very
much your talk very much
I've heard that Philadelphia was very
rough for him and I'm just wondering in
the different cities was the extent of
the racism and the hatred and the
threats the reflection of the geographic
makeup of the teammates or the manager
or the ownership of the team were just
the city in general and a second
question is what can you briefly say
about Larry Doby and what he went
through on the kind of person he was I
think that it was particularly each city
to various environments I mean in
Philadelphia I think it was largely the
result of Ben Chapman the manager of the
Phillies who was well known as a racist
and an anti-semite at the time he'd been
in trouble before for some remarks he'd
made about Jews during his playing
career with the Yankees and and he
instructed his team and I talked to some
of the old guys who were still around
were on a team he instructed the team to
give Jackie a hard time to really bust
them as best they could and I what's
interesting to me about the comments too
is that they were not only designed to
upset Jackie Robinson they were designed
to drive a wedge between Robinson and
his white teammates and this was in the
first week of this first month of the
season when it was still new and it was
still a sense that Robinson if he didn't
hit would go back to the minors and
these remarks that the phillies were or
shouting we're not just calling him
names but they were but they were
suggesting that he was going to give his
teammates diseases or that he might rape
the wives of the other players things
that were really insidious and and
touched on a nerve that was very
sensitive at the time when you look at
at segregation and what some of those
issues were that really the hot-button
issues for whites so I think that the
ballplayers knew it Ben Chapman knew it
and it was especially vicious and it
varied in some cities I think it was
southern crowds in other cities it was
Jackie Robinson was very well received
and your second question was about Larry
Doby Toby came along I was kind of
surprised to realize it's just 11 weeks
after Jackie Robinson you know he makes
his debut with the Cleveland Indians and
becomes the first African American
player in the American League
but Toby had a much harder time that
first year you know one of the great
things Branch Rickey
it was he brought Robinson along slowly
gave him a year in the minor leagues to
prepare and gave him spring training to
get used to big-league pitching and get
used to his teammates dough became in
cold one day he's playing in the Negro
Leagues the next day he's playing for
the Indians and the big leagues and
that's a tough transition for anybody to
make and on top of that the Indians
didn't have a position for him to play
so he was relegated to pinch-hitting all
season long so you take somebody who's
got no experience in the minor leagues
and you ask him to come up to bat maybe
two or three times a week he had no
chance no to acclimate himself as a
result of that he fared pretty poorly in
this first year he became a great great
hitter as you know but in 1947 he made
very little impact and I think that's
testament to just how much thought
Branch Rickey had put into this approach
because if Jackie Robinson to come in
and just were served as a pinch hitter
all year the message that we sent that
he sent that America received would not
have been nearly as loud and as strong
and I don't I don't think we'd be
celebrating the anniversary in the grand
way that we are now 60 years later
Jonathan you mentioned problems with the
Cardinals and this is going back to his
previous question if you know that story
broke that the Cardinals were planning
on boycotting Robinson and not playing
him playing against the Dodgers if they
if they played him I was going to ask
you relatively recently there have been
suggestions that the Pittsburgh Pirates
were also planning to boycott and I'm
just wondering if you had any
information on that there was a new
story about I think was 10 years ago on
Robinson's 50th anniversary suggesting
that this was really a league wide
strike that the Dixie Walker had been
trying to foment a league wide strike by
writing letters to players that he
thought would be allies on every team in
the league and asking them that we would
pick a day and we would all refuse to
play it doesn't hold up
nobody has ever just seen one of those
letters not none of them has ever
survived nobody ever wrote about it at
the time 60 years ago and I think
more likely happen is that there was
some loudmouth talking trash and and
that's and I'm not saying that because I
out of pure conjecture that's what fret
that's what the Frick the president the
National League's that he believed was
the case he gave an interview many
interviews late in life and said that he
thought the whole thing had been blown a
proportion by the media god forbid the
media would do such a thing but he
believed that that it was all
exaggerated and I tend to think that it
certainly never got any traction if
there was any kind of a league wide
effort to to keep Robinson out of the
game yes yes my memory is a little weak
but I thought that the professional
football had been integrated before 1947
I'm not sure about basketball but could
you comment on that
professional football integrated at
roughly the same time I believe it was
the fall of 40 might have been the
winter of four it might have been just
before Robinson played his first big
league game but after Robinson had
already been signed to a minor league
contract so Robinson came first in that
he was signed to the Dodgers and played
in the minors and then I think NFL our
what they called 48 okay so it was just
after but it really made no impact at
the time it was very little noticed at
the time because football just wasn't
really on people's radar screen baseball
was such the dominant game in America in
1947 that even a football had come first
I think it wouldn't have made that kind
of impact on the only really big effect
it would have had a football had
integrated a little earlier is that
Jackie Robinson probably would have
picked football over baseball because he
was a much better football player
right and baseball has been integrated
to turn of the century to until white
players essentially forced them out and
then created this artificial color line
yes the second question concerning uh
the the timing of the commissioners of
baseball Aliza that Kennesaw Mountain
Landis was strongly opposed to any
integration but then we had a happy
Chandler who was actually a former
governor of Kentucky which is and he
supported this this integration could
you comment on that please
yeah Chandler was a very strong
supporter of integration as far as I
could tell you know Branch Rickey went
to him and said do I have your support
to do this and Chandler said absolutely
and one of the other interesting notes
this famous game where Reese and
Robinson supposedly embraced in
Cincinnati Chandler was at that game and
had it happened had this phenomenal
moment occurred that that silenced the
crowd and made such a strong impression
I can't believe that happy Chandler who
who loved to spin yarns and love the
tell stories I'd love to claim
responsibility for everything good that
ever happened from the Sun coming up in
the morning but happy Chandler would
have let that pass without commenting on
it at some time and happy Chandler
talked often about being at that game
and talked about congratulating Jackie
Robinson and shaking his hand and posing
for pictures with him but he never
mentioned seeing Jackie Robinson and Pee
Wee Reese together are you know with
arms around each other so I think that's
further evidence that the myths
that that particular myth has been
inflated over time anything else well
thank you all very much for l-dub sorry
this one more question yeah you
mentioned that he had no roommates white
roommates in this first year did he ever
have a white roommate in his major
league career that's a great question I
wonder if any of our diehard Dodger fans
in the audience know that III think I
know you had black roommates throughout
most of his career Campanella and
newcome but I don't know that he ever
had a white room and I don't I would
suspect not I would be surprised to
learn otherwise but if anybody can give
me an answer on that contact me later
let me know
well thank you all very much for coming
it's been a pleasure The Wall Street
Journal's Jonathan Ike on his new book
opening day the story of Jackie
Robinson's first season for more
information visit Jonathan Icom